for
[Music]
ha
for
well rip my tongue out and spank my
bottom red
again welcome this is the
Triforce I am Robert Handler here with
uhet brown and we are playing Legend of
Zelda uh the idea of this weekly show
Thursdays 11: a.m. Pacific is that we
will tackle the various things you can
do in Hyrule in this game and there are
plenty yeah and we're going to try to do
our best to sort of set little
challenges for ourselves um just for fun
just gonna goof off uh today
snowboarding first and
foremost uh this is like one of the most
exciting little things in you know in
the game it's not really hidden but it's
not really made a big deal about it but
we've done our best to sort of find some
roots that we think are interesting and
uh we're going to try to like set a
little bit of a challenge for ourselves
where uh we're going to each tackle or
maybe get like five to 10 minutes and
try to see how many animals we can take
out while boarding while boarding uh how
many tricks we can pull off
um and within that time limit we will
sort of give ourselves points and see
who wins yeah style points and uh at the
end of each 10-minute run uh you guys in
the chat we will be watching
consistently uh give us a score N9 out
of 10 8 out of 10 0 out of 10 one out of
a thousand one
sure uh and yeah we will definitely uh
tally all those scores up I'm going to
get a 10-minute timer ready oh nice all
right it's a little competition all
right
so let's do it all right so I also have
a nice little map here yeah give him an
idea of where we are you got it or
actually I don't even think we're around
there right now but if you want to cut
to gameplay I can show them where I am
sure and then next time when we go to
your Mountain uh oh oh you got your own
favorite Mountain that's yeah yeah uh so
this quick little run I'm going to use
to uh go from Snowy mountaintops down in
the desert and try to kill as many bears
and flamingos and wolves as I can uh all
right so let's see
one point for small game that's right
two points for Bears that's right and
moose mooses are the trophy kill yeah
and they're tough and by the way I got a
little surprise for
you the person who
kills the Moose the other one has to
wear the hat as a little bit of a shame
goodness uh so these kills only count if
you're on the board again and if you
have to get off the board you lose a
point that's right
um but you can do that to sort of like
reset yourself if you need to get back
up the mountain right yada yada yada um
link is going to be mostly naked I've
got him wearing we get our own headgear
of choice I'm choosing the I forget what
it's called but it's like the face mask
with the scarf cuz it's cold outside
sure is um yeah and you can use Elixir
if you'd like what I mean oh damn I mean
you're going to be losing Health the
whole time you're yeah well that's the
challenge my friend I love it all right
let's get this started
nice choice and board there Peter thank
you thank
you oh it's
on little bit of a Rhino kill oh wow
you're you're doing it oh off you can't
kill
oh
[__] I don't know that might be a little
bit of a
deduction well how many Rhino worth
that's
[Laughter]
only he did not know what hit him come
here boy come come on come on did I get
him you bet I did so where are you exact
oh my God uh [__] uh where am I right
here near the G Highlands uh Roka
snowfield I tried to get up to mount aot
that thing to the west and it would not
let me go o nice oh [__] God damn it how
many points have I lost now a
lot again in the chat ah you're raiding
this at the end so far I mean I'm doing
a hunting run right like I could be
prioritized
okay tricks if I wanted
to
nice you ever snowboard like this in
real life oh yeah all the
time oh and the clim is now ready don't
worry about that the climate is now
changing look at
this oh
[__] but I Live still on
it wow see this is a route I do not ever
take
I've lost count of how many tricks I've
done let's call this a practice run just
to sort of show people what we're trying
to do and then we'll go to your Peak
where we've got the same track that we
can run to yeah yeah yeah yeah oh get
some speed oh that's going to hurt it's
going to hurt your
score ooh two out of 10 I'm seeing the
unknown
clone oh excuse me negative 2 out of 10
that's damn harsh hey I you're making up
I'm not the judge hey man you're still
warming up
literally oh oh
oh that's going to do
it oh well you'll get back up still got
10 minutes all right all right five out
of 10 we didn't even start okay yeah
let's let's go to the actual mountain
top that was just a taste let's go to uh
what is it mea's mea's
spot the the place that is like the
designated like snowboarding area in the
game uh it's like Sal selmies I think
it's called called s me spot let's see
what we got here uh-huh uh-huh we're
getting there yeah zoom in a little bit
over there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
there we
go
what so I also made a little bit of a uh
score here so I will keep this
updated again if you're joining us
welcome to Tri Force we are snowboarding
today there are plenty of runs and
slopes that's what like the essence of
this first episode I would say is that
like when I found the hebra mountain
which is where we are now my God you
it's just tons of slopes and paths and
you can even rate them like black
diamond to like bunny slopes uh this
game is really great I need some
food I don't care what it is three 10
that's fine that's fine I'm not here to
win I'm just here to have
fun I love it all right show them What
You're Made Of I'm going to start a
timer for you when you're ready pick
rali scale is now
ready you got it let me just update this
real quick that's the current you're
losing points right now oh am I I yeah
I'm going to start the clock already
you're taking too
long
okay where are
we I'm okay okay I got okay uhhuh okay
all right so you do the countdown down
to three to one and I'll hit start on
one oh can I'm going to change my shield
dude change your Shield if you want to
funeral oh all right go for
it yeah uhhuh what you going to do okay
one point oh moose I'll give you another
point oh
shoot no can't do it no yes come with me
my friend I off track it takes two oh to
make a thing go oh no it just takes one
oh sh wear the hat damn it it's behind
you I'm still in it to win it
oh losing it I I got off track so that's
the thing about the wildlife here is get
a little yeah put that hat on get a
little distracted so look at this look
at this over the headphones I don't know
does that work I did not stress test oh
yeah do some tricks ah yeah I didn't
finish cut it short okay come
on this guy right here oh
man dude get the other one too what are
you
doing got oh we almost got two
that's
close you know bomb arrows little bit of
Splash damage I have what do we say 189
arrows across the various types you can
definitely you can pick your your arrow
you don't have to use the bomb
ones yeah baby oh I could have done that
oh man yeah if you can grab a butterfly
while snowboarding 10 points oh yeah
yeah I like that I'm not keeping track
of your points right now by the way nor
am I those chat in the chat who are
watching this obviously you would be uh
add your scores oh what we got here oh
these guys suck oh I can turn all the
way
around I've never done that all right so
you got a moose you got a dog you got a
rhino did you get a rhino I can't
remember I don't I don't think so I'll
give you the Rhino why not okay Moose
Dog Rhino bat so that's you got a total
of and that's 720 Five Points oh
[__] oh look at this guy oh nice do
see this is a pretty good run not too
bad uhoh oh waa what's on here oh dude
come on what are you doing twofer no
what nope you blew it
you I'm wasting your
arrows
cool ah that was a harsh
Landing what's sup
dog
oh
yeah oh there a RH there two dogs what
are you going to
do
damn oh I forgot you can do board grabs
yeah never forget yeah get those boids
oh damn they were dumb most birds are
pretty D fair
enough uh-oh uh-oh what's going on here
what's going on here oh so this is we
talking about this today so this is
generally one of the end games cuz all
the slopes kind of converge here I came
from a different side yeah when I
dropped
down all
right hold on one
second no don't do it hold on you going
a selfie
[Laughter]
yeah was that a good one I think it was
pretty good is it good I was it uh it's
pretty
good all right you still got six minutes
you want to call your one now you want
to go back up and take a different one
okay maybe six is too long let's call it
five all right five is good you got
minute and a half what are you going to
do uh I'm going to kill this
[__] you just go I I got another
minute all right I'm going to be
generous I'm going to make up a score of
uh 22 points 22 points six out of
10 I got an
8.2 used all my damn bomb
[Music]
arrows I think I think we'll call it
what don't we call it a seven out of 10
what do you think can we do that seven
seven good a good out of 10
s.8 I forgot I wearing this hat 1227
yeah you
are unfortunately you're just one moose
death away I'm telling you there we
go I found that in my closet moose why I
I have random headgear apparently so you
were lucky because you got that uh that
Health Boost from that Divine beast
power so you got resurrected you
jerk all right um I'm going to
take let me update this uh score here
yeah yeah which did you go east or west
you know what Peter let's take a look at
this this map I made and it's actually
kind of useless considering
that you have a map on you but I wanted
to do it live so I went a I went around
here uh took the uh the North Route of
uh hebra Tundra I think I came around
here around the North Crest and then I
came down here no no I take that back
right around here around uh Byron's snow
I can't read it you can't read snow
shelf and then we ended here oh okay so
that's the route remember that okay I'm
taking an extreme route uh I got dogs
barking at me already hold on get to the
top of this Summit dog put your dog on a
leash all right I'm going to go you took
the what
route uh so I went around yeah yeah yeah
I'm going to go I'm going to go
Southwest that sounds great that's a
good way to go these dogs are dude you
know what it's probably been a while
since they've
eaten clear a path
boys all right but I I'm going to switch
it up uh yeah we we got work in there
you know why don't you change some of
your uh your your mask there any any
other
stylish uh yeah that'll
do sty point I guess bomb arrows are
really the thing though right for taking
out big game yeah maybe we should change
it up you I'm not going to kill that
animal and leave its
meat all right you know you you can
freeze meat give me my shield did you
know that oh I knew it and it's on oh
timer
shoot all right it's 11 13 uh-huh oh oh
no no uh-oh he's on the run time is of
the
essence is that cheating cuz I wasn't
technically no no you're that was that
was legal oh he's still
going survival of the fittest oh you're
losing it shoot for the stars look at
that face oh
God again if you're joining us this is
Triforce we're snowboarding today I'm a
moose he's a moose if you are joining us
now and wondering why he's wearing a
moose hat it's because uh we're trading
off the shame trophy kill so if he kills
it I wear it and so forth Fox no
way it's a
decoy oh wow nice black diamond oh oh
dear all right oh what do we
got I'm going to count this as
snowboarding
yeah God
no oh man that that's a nice little pass
over there I know but I blew
it all right I still got time I'm going
to jump back up there I'm going to take
a different route this is not working
out that's fine what am I getting two
out of 10 one three out of 10 uh let me
check the let me check the chat
here you guys uh are enjoying this oh
I'm I'm seeing 10 out of 10 * 10 10
minus 10 equals a 10 so far so far so
good
yeah you you were going to wear this
stupid hat I kind of want to so hurry up
don't worry I got it I have another hat
with you yeah it's just like a snow snow
hat I thought was you know why not have
fun dude why aren't you wearing it
aren't you cold link wears
[Music]
hats
great yeah
continue your
run oh nice I'm feeling
happy 0.1 out of 10 damn harsh
damn car
[Music]
it oh oh ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow
ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow
ow yep keep going get that momentum come
on come on come on foxy
cleopatras those guys are those guys are
pretty tough that's just when I'm behind
the
bat oh yeah look at this what do we got
a [__] uhoh I think you need to make a
right there is nowhere to go where are
oh oh
uh all right oh it's off change of
game that's right bill you do not want
this happening in your
run oh a [__] [__] I
missed this guy's name is Frost
tailes no it's not I
know
[__] if I can kill him while boarding
that's still counts oh it's not going to
happen though this guy's going to take
some time
oh
God sorry link oh I wonder where his
face is near his butt
think you think L link hates you right
now
oh
Mount I've actually never killed one of
these guys
before I'm in yeah oh
no
yeah yeah yeah
I think you can climb on him
oh
well X Games just got a lot more
extreme uh so I've never finished uh
Twilight Princess and I was looking
around YouTube last night to figure out
like all right who's the best
snowboarder in breath of the wild uh on
YouTube and there's really not I
couldn't find any clips that like really
stood out to me but I did find a clip um
from Twilight Princess apparently
there's this like snowboard racing game
kind of similar to what you did Mario 64
where you like slid down that hill but
links's racing on a board did you did
you have as much control or abilities
it's pretty simple you couldn't really
do tricks but you were going a lot
faster and there were like you had to
like jump off of things and like really
time to make sure that you weren't uh
you know falling through like gaps and
putf Falls that kind of thing yeah yeah
I mean man we were talking about this
morning like if only you had just a
couple more mov moves like a like a flip
or something I got to imagine for the
DLC like Nintendo's got to recognize how
much people love this
right let's go classic do
it too bad link sorry dude you don't
want to wear the gift
mask just do
it oh eat some meat eat some meat yeah
eat some meat Chow Down what you got for
what you what you makeing here dude I
got I got meat for simmered fruit I got
a lot of raw
meat can you eat raw meat raw oh yeah
and I do a lot you
animal yes yes yes faster faster faster
yeah that I wish link could get stomach
aches oh or get fat or something yeah
right okay so oh what's going on shut
up all right I
say so wait where are we again
Jesus I hate those freeze
bats
Keys just going keep running away from
it use the uh oh oh yeah yeah use that
thing the meteor
Rod ooh like that just like that what
the hell yeah indeed oh my god I've
never seen that well play 100 hours and
talk to
me okay so here's the thing I'm going up
here how
it won't take too long I don't think oh
okay I know the
route there's a shrine nearby should
probably kill that
thing there's one thing about you know I
like the idea of the sensor but I don't
need the
audio so these guys are
carrying rods so the rods upgrade like
as you play more and kill more of these
enemies the stuff they drop gets better
so at first you can just cast like a
little bit of ice but then these dudes I
think have like a blizzard Rod maybe
it's called m whatever whatever kill him
how yeah what else is there like I've
seen the the shock one which is gnarly
it's just the it's basically the three
elements yeah it'd be cool if there was
like a poison one
or other
ones man looks so good right now oh of
course that's going to take a lot
though we need this check
point you any wood Peter
yeah wait does doing dang it does doing
that melt them faster oh use your use
your meteor Rod
oh God you're smart why are you here
come here
Medias you let it recharge that's enough
you're
good
ah
ice ice do you remember the names of any
of these shes that was one of the first
things we talked about I was like no
after the first one I was like yeah good
luck no I have not remembered a single
one uh question from EAS e69 6 can you
drink mustard can you drink mustard
technically is that pertaining to the I
don't think it's will we I think it's
can we I uh to say I like mustard a lot
you slug back some Dijon first thing in
the morning not a fan of Dijon uh more
of just a classic hind yellow oh so
here's this lift this is the uh this is
the ultimate lift on Mount hebra here
I'm just going to lay it out there you
let a moose go by Oh you mean like a
wind lift that was a rhino yeah wind no
there was a moose down there F maybe I
want to wear the
hat okay so Dam maybe now I want to wear
the
hat man can you can you imagine wearing
this
fit like in real I want to like buy a
customade snowboard that's like a high
rule shield and just hit Heavenly when
you first told me that there was a lift
I thought you meant like a traditional
ski lift like where you sit on a chair
and I was really hoping that there was
some like awkward NPC that you had to
talk to the entire time he's like ho 20
rubies to get to the top oh you got
three stamas Jesus my hearts are only at
10 traded them in oh right I just found
that guy yeah it's weird he's like not
that hard to find but also not super
obvious yeah it I came across it by
accident dude you are going to die
before you get to the top hell
no suck it up like his one eye his one
eye
Squints hello
Fox o boomerang oh you've been here hey
buddy all right more
food
uh-huh still pretty cold
here oh well then have a Peppa oh don't
you need to cook it to make it oh to
activate it yeah ah rats I'll have some
meat then eat that
meat okay look at this all right there
oh boy so this is definitely a black
diamond where is it oh I can go
that rough diamond do you want to do you
want to save it here yeah why not can
save that's a great idea just throwing
my game to the stream just getting rid
of all my money and arrows it happens
it's all right yeah whatever four out of
10 let's change
that I'm going to go with the uh not
that I'm gonna go with the uh radiant
Shield why
not you are technically wearing a mask
that is known as the radiant mask ask
[Laughter]
so hi my name's link and I'm on top of
Mount
hebra Zelda I love
[Laughter]
you that Shield is just getting worked
come on what are you doing God
trying what are you doing I blew
it why is this in oh I know what it is
cuz oh it's that bow in
particular damn it
Dam damn it contact
oh God damn it ah I panicked we suck
again oh this is nice I've never been
here
before where are we just a little check
Pita Stone Grove clearly I've never done
I've never been there before haven't
done anything
here oh you are you just passing up
points
Oh you mean like this you're walking oh
deduction Hey Oh I thought he was going
to charge
me I think you would die if he hit you
at this
point why am I not there we go uh let's
see the jce 81 suggests that maybe
instead of shooting animals we simply
jump over
them that might that might be the way to
do it game changer that might be the way
to do it let's try that
ow wipe out oh shoot can he recover he's
yeah he's
uhoh I'm on uh probably the lowest
heart you are risking everything right
now else you got
here I'm sorry for eating all your good
stuff no you're
not I don't
care
Apple it's too bad you can't also eat
like five at once when you're five and
choke man this game maybe it's just a 9
out of 10 I don't know what I was
thinking oh look at this can you melt
that while it's rolling okay I'll give
you 10 points oh that's a thing that's a
thing oh yes look at it yes oh and then
can I clear
it come on
ah the problem here Peter is that it you
know keeps amassing more watch get out
of the way
oh Redemption
Redemption right in the butt oh and down
he goes and on the hack goes for
you take it
yes all right oh oh oh oh oh uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh uhhuh way too many things
happening in this
hat uh
yeah can you take a picture no you can't
can't use any of your powers huh yeah
all right blow it
up oh so
close mhm
mhm mhm how many licks does it take to
get to the center of a snowball
ah oh man
shoot we're shooting too much maybe it's
distracting oh guess that's the
end what the hell is this
place
whoa uh oh we oh I been here yeah oh oh
wait were you the one that was doing
this yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah well where are
we Kopi Kopi kop cop drifts Copic cop
cozy okay coat wck drifts Peter you're
up let's do it oh no wait let's reload
that safe
yeah sorry that controller is
warm that's way I like it uh all right
so shall I make this run about jumping
over animals yes we'll see what we can
do there we are changing it up and if
tighter shot on the hat oh look at
that you got any move sound effects
I don't know that was a good one oh yeah
reload that save that hot
save uh what do you got a Moose
sound uh what is a
moose a moose uh how about how
about that's a legit moose says
goob I have actually have two of those I
think I have another moose hat lying
around I don't know where I get them no
literally I don't remember where I got
these hats all right so uh uh oh man
imagine if I could somehow make it off
that to continue down but there's no way
you can get enough momentum right let's
take a look at the
map so here we are on top of uh old
smokey old smokey so this is the route
yeah it's it's real rough you you can't
recover from up here but I think there
are some lifts around here maybe over
here that you can uh utilize um Peter
what if you took this route sorry I was
abusing a COR
aquet what if you took this route over
here Northwest
uhhuh right through uh the uh the North
Crest uhhuh come come around here right
and then the North summit you want to
make a a right around that let's see if
you can utilize the entire Northwestern
area here I've learned something very
important today which is to not give
Robert a microphone and a m map oh no
and uh wrong scene but we're back in
it all right so first of all I'm just
going to have some fun with my C I love
boomerangs wow I'm going to show off you
you didn't even catch it it went right
into your
holster whoops oh my God
that ch ch ch ch ch
[Laughter]
choke yeah dude where'd you find that
your mom's house shut up that gu I sleep
yeah oh no oh there goes your pride and
joy you reload what he's guy I had no
idea I fell asleep over here oh
God all right do I have a bow do I no
how about no Bows Oh right only spin
moves jumping over animals only spin
moves well like if if you want to attack
an animal okay who is
aggressive this is this is it this is
not going to work going to say that
right now oh what was my last run there
how many points score wise yeah uh I
think you got uh 92 points 92 points out
of
10 oh I just noticed oh come on link I
really believed in you this time don't
give up the fight my last room was
pretty bad I'm going I'm
I'm eight out of 10 my last run
no I'm bring it down to a no to a five
I'm missing the action
here
oh little bastards don't do it no but
you said to
freeze I didn't see that that doesn't
count you go again reload that
save I don't like wearing this hat I'm
gonna be
honest kill a
moose as long as I can jump over a moose
which I don't even think is possible
oh that's right so I'm screwed no okay
moose you can take out with bow and
arrow let's do that fine so how am I
trying to do this again did I go the
wrong way no sure you're going down yeah
so a little bit to the right where
you're looking you want to hug like d
this the main course I think is the best
way to go all right I want to well it
like I want to see if you can like hug
the right edge of the map get the most
out of the Run well let's find out Rob h
mhm mhm that's a nice choice in
Shield nice this is good this is good oh
see this is dangerous you're going to
want to start veering to the left yeah
uh yeah
uh-huh good
call oh nicely
done
oh oh oh
my get you
oh this is the
Run
yeah okay look for look for
lifts ooh can you make it oh there's no
way I'm going to make that or maybe the
next one make the next uhoh if you drop
on it a [__] you I'll wear the hat the
rest of the time if I drop on it yeah if
you drop on
it Moes are so
funny and weak apparently thank you very
much uh I never knew that three pieces
of meat that's all there is to a
moose so this
route I'd be wary I I did this oh look
at every time enough with the
howling yeah I think you're in some uh
Uncharted Territory coming up yep
good whoa
yeah yeah this is the North Crest man
shoot I got to
eat beautiful N9 out of 10 I'm seeing it
from America
first I agree that was some fine
boarding come on
camera birdie oh ow ow ow ow ow
where are we going what are we doing I
don't oh oh you know what that is I
don't want to
know
that's this is probably one of one of
the more intensive cororo seeds so it
seems and what is that
[Laughter]
thing
there's only one thing to
do I don't know if you can well we're
going to find
out yeah see I get on it whoa what is
that take me with
[Laughter]
you oh these
guys my
hair all right well I think that does it
for this run where else can you go I
have oh okay for sure why
not look like a
1080 all
right next
up you can take off the hat I'm going to
take off the hat it actually it was
getting pretty warm all right let's go
back to that
save should we try um doing some grass
or desert sledding after the next run
pick a spot we think looks juicy I'm
into it all
righty have you done I mean you said you
I I have not really hit the desert that
often well then you haven't really lived
I know clearly uh although it it does
operate the same as snow right so your
Shield is not well in fact in the desert
you have less opportunities for like
rocks or like gravel to kind of like
make an appearance
oh what do you think
here
yeah yeah go Axel
Rose oh
uh dude you're in my
shot
okay oh okay gulp oh here we do it can
you jump no can
you whoops sadly you cannot ride moose I
know right it breaks my heart this game
sucks
here we go for every complaint we should
deduct a point from the score I gave the
game
break uh-huh
uh-huh uh
go have sear
ready can you do
it so this is like the actual oh shoot
okay we're going this way I believe you
can do it jump it jump it
yeah oh you want that he only does it
sometimes
yeah whoa what was that what a playful
boy oh oh this is exactly what I
wanted can you make it to that pancake
in the sky what how does that happen oh
I don't want to go that way uh-oh hit
the
birds I did not mean to do that that
meat is bigger than the
[Laughter]
animal birds are weird all right all
right Birds what even are they
yeah go for it
mhm over the
Rocks hit him in the butt hit him in the
butt hit him in the butt right in the
butt little speed here oh I think I know
this I think I think I know this slope
oh jump it jump it good God man come on
ah think I
needed think I need speed here
whoa are you kidding
me wow
what oh that be cool hey you were born
for this baby I Was Born This
Way SL you're going to you're going to
die very soon I think can I make this
Ridge Rock
Ridge what yeah what sorcer that paw
pumpkins carrots stem and all
herb check
on all
right
I I don't I can't go there I'm losing it
do it do it do it kill it crunch
oh nuh-uh uh
uhuh and then we're going to end it with
a sploosh the nice I'm going to land it
right here on this oh wait wait wait
hold on hold on drop a bomb land and
blow it up the moment you land okay if
you can my okay let me think about the
moves that are
required it's like algebra order of
operations first and foremost
yes it's it was too far up or too close
to the
ground all right Peter your turn let's
hit the sand take me to the
sand here we
go uh yeah screw it all right let's go
to
gudo where do I want to be where do I
want to be Dan says it's Dan says yo
link put some clothes on it's cold
dog is that the way he talks oh is Dam
aork that's definitely the way he talks
yeah and it's all
cap
all right all right I'm going to
pick here so I'm curious
because you know the desert that I've
seen is very flat however you can like
you can get speed on like surprisingly
like uh not that steep slopes uh you
just have to believe Rob right and you
got to wax you got to wax that
board man I wish there was more to this
boarding
thing oh your board's too rough dude got
to make some wax um you could get it
from the The Beehive the rub some man we
should yeah we should have made this
game what I'm secretly hoping is that
Nintendo decides to make like a Mario
Kart like but with the snowboarding
physics of this
game oh man can you imagine like yes I
just did just like three friends just
carving up hebra all right where so oh
wow so you could kind of go down the I
kind yeah I want to try to take this
route that you guys are seeing from the
top left of the screen whoa
yeah you can get pardon
me all right bear with me while I make
my way over there I think I can make a a
pretty long run down that damn that
looks look at
that spank it it's got to get there I
like it yeah you'll get
there how many hours have you played now
you know what's funny is I finally just
looked
on my switch
135 wait yeah how I don't know I think I
so I will be honest and say that I think
some some of it yes maybe AFK but uh
like time lapse I did that once right
that was like that was like probably
three hours right uh that's crazy though
dude I'm impressed I thought I thought I
was alone in my like 110 hours but yeah
wow well it's funny is like I feel like
I've been doing as you have completed
the story and I have not i' only I mean
I've only really done like two three of
the dungeons but right uh I just been
doing like a lot of the side stuff yeah
yeah you you've been working on guide
work as well like trying to make sure
that we have like footage for things
that you know force you to play stuff
you probably wouldn't
yeah um but what's funny is hearing I
was talking with Justin last night and
he uh this was like the fifth time in
the day he's like oh did you did you do
this I'm like no no I was like how I was
like you know we were fortunate enough
to get this game like like two weeks
earlier and I just feel like he's seing
a lot more than I don't know what I'm
doing wrong other than
oh really oh come on
really now you just ticked off it
teaches
me yeah dude I'm still you know I play
this game at least like two hours a day
like after work and there really is no
shortage of stuff that I'm I'm
discovering yeah it's just as simple as
opening up the map looking for like
titles of things in the environment be
like yep I've clearly done nothing there
I'm going to go there and then I get
distracted by like 100 things along the
way so
close I thought a neat trick like when
you're climbing and you're say you are
running out of stamina like on a certain
slopes you can like run diagonally yeah
oh that's good one no but like you can
disengage the climb on like certain
slopes and kind of run in place and and
regain a lot of your stamina yeah but I
think when it's this steep I don't think
that work yeah not here like maybe no
not even there
God I love a to be young
again all right got zukes do I go up
there yeah for the Cuda cuz I can drop
in then check your map check your
map
uh
yeah it's it's one more
Peak wait yeah just want to make sure
I've got this run
again he'll fly off the cliff
right yes the answer to that is yes
Goodbye Oh what was going through his
head did you see me uh you see
me all right so I'm going to try to okay
yeah did you over no I didn't ever shoot
it all right I've got something in mind
let's see what happens
here not going to do it and you're also
not going to put on clothes oh what why
would I do that I don't know apparently
people think you should wear some
clothes heck
no l nipples for days I mean look how
awesome this guy he looks
like he just looks like he's been around
and has seen a lot of
stuff board shorts oh nice okay this
Shield is going to break I can tell you
that right now sounds like it gr oh hey
oh uhoh
o wait all of that oh was fall damage
shoot apology stream that's all
right all right fine here you go oh do
it up okay um I think there's one more
route that I have in
mind yeah let's check it out okay all
right oh oh how convenient uh bummer I
really wanted to show off that that run
that sucks we can go back nah it took
too long to get there and we can go back
to a different part of the desert after
you run fair enough is this no this is
not the say okay yeah so we got load
this I will say s let's put on some new
head gear let's mix up the headgear you
know I don't have is the the flame
breaker frame oh it just looks like a
welding mask yeah yeah I like that one
uh did you get the one that we talked
about the one that like is the most
badass I forget what it's called the
gold
shoot no I forgot to get that it's got
like six eyes you've got to kill that
big monster in the desert and get it
yeah shut up lank you're
good hey guys really I know you're
having fun
but no that's not visible enough this do
it
[Laughter]
I yeah I'm totally cool with this his
his eyes are not obstructed at all can't
see well or unless he has
all of those eyes all those eyes 12
eyes eat it all right be
somebody I will I will all right we kind
of did that route thinking more uh oh
yeah I mean look what we got going down
here just look dead ahead there look how
far that can take you well you know what
what if we started over here oh oh yeah
meant to be isn't that the one that
you've done before no it's funny enough
it's actually not well uh cuz that one
is all the
way it has to
be you know that as as in the beginning
map right like that's
way no cuz no okay
no sorry my mind working and conflicting
itself cuz this one yeah it didn't have
a tree on it this is perfect this is
going to be tough
too real narrow slopes I think you can
do it
see
[Laughter]
memories o yeah oh that is Nar Rocky
too three two one
drop H can I get on this whoa what's
tied around that tree where on the base
of the tree oh can you slide down you
can just let go and fall
ow god that hurt my
head you know this is this is in in
memor or in memory of the guy who did
this run and
died whoops oh that I was trying that
move the other day where you do this oh
the infinite run Sprint thing ridiculous
it's I don't think it's just I don't
think it's as fast as sprinting but it's
like super
close yeah yeah yeah it's it's enough
all right great all right great run
great start I also like the quick drop
like this except you have to have more
of a slant here we go
party get get out woy oh
okay oh Choo Cho who put those
there oh horrible horrible that's a
deduction all right
uh-huh yeah let's do
it well I don't know I expected all
right uh-huh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
DJ
nope oh this is pretty good so far oh
look at that not too
shabby I like this I like this slope
carve
it nope that could have been
cool that was
cooler come
on you know hit that doggy oh I missed
him good camo all right I'm going to
drop oh two moose dude how could one man
be so lucky and a bear is that a bear
behind you
where oh it's another
Rhino oh my God I totally forgot
something I made a mark of it up
pause
you no sorry I'm stalling eat eat eat
eat yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
good that wasn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
NOP yeah know would be that was
expensive no
what I almost want to make this a series
where basically we just save after
breaking all of our equipment and then I
have to somehow regain it before we go
back next week you're just working with
like lame traveler swords and wooden
Shields
yeah bomb bomb bomb bomb thought that
would be
cooler oh okay okay are you ready for
this all right let's try this again I'm
ready for this dump dump D how do I get
my shield away hey oh
hi you know the
[Laughter]
lodges
okay this one more
shot um yeah that was a nice here let's
let's recap where was that let's see we
we were over here I think we took it to
the
uh T talento talento Peak I think that's
where we were you don't
know dang it what did you so kakar Rico
Village is karaoke
Village what is g was gudo Dorito
Village no Rito ritoo Dorito Village he
said where I went to the uh I found the
the Dorito place no and that I did not
pronounce it Dorito I
combined no
fine there's another one I
R Mount
ROM I want to do the desert but
there it's too bad there's you can't
really snowboard around here yeah oh
oh uh no that's that's that shit's weak
over there it is I got all this you got
you got nothing dude I mean on grass
you're going to you're going to ruin
your gear
man that sounds like a challenge all
right uh well let's think here let's
let's judge by this I'm done thinking
Rob I'm I minored in cartography in
thought that too if you look over
here look at these slopes look at you
could the highlands there that could be
nice I don't know if it's that high
though I mean but I get up there to yeah
good point I mean okay look I could go
to this Tower it' be weak I could do a
thing but I'd really just I'd rather do
this what if you took it to the extreme
heat yeah but you can't really snowboard
on there's some path Vol there's some
paths I'll let you do it it all right
fine later and I'm sure it'll be amazing
and you'll show me up shut
up Rob love Rob lovees compliments don't
be it makes him super comfortable it
does that's a great shirt you got
buddy if you're just joining us we are
snowboarding and we are the Triforce and
we are the Triforce we are not that
impressive but we like to think we are
we we try a lot oh dude wet grass is
even better even better no one's going
to be on the slopes in this rain see I
need this map man you're telling me no
map on the screen but think turn off if
you
want cuz yeah I'm trying to figure out
east and uh yeah I'm doing it sorry do
it sorry y'all turn off the pro
mode I'm just a
norm is this DLC yes
yes
I wonder uh sometimes you just you like
to think every minute detail I was about
to say what if the rain is actually like
taking less damage on your Shield I
think the rain is good for it okay I
really wasn't heading the right way
where where am I really trying to go
here hey good news it's not that cold so
you're not dying TI I'm going to put on
a sick outfit before I do this okay I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to keep
my belly exposed oh my my
god oh
oh yeah actually maybe I'll do oh no I
want the belt belt
oh right I broke my shield I want to
meet yeah you did not seem hostile at
all in
that good picture than do
it
yes that is a
Prime thank God I brought my par don't
work out the way I hope they
do oh yeah oh
yeah oh look at that on the right there
right little
Crest
yeah show me another
move
uh did did you see that one yet yeah I
saw that oh yeah all the
way not
today no flower games oh oh here's the
lodge it's my town I'm going to run away
from that so I don't spoil anything good
people um [__] that sucked nah it's all
right you want I just thought of
something what do you want okay this is
the ultimate
Challenge go here
yeah from Mountain to mountain or from
Island to Island no no no no you told me
about this you told me about this liar
there there is a there's a wooden plank
it's real hard I don't know if we can do
it there's no way I did I really yeah
you said it was there was a challenge
that was like one of like the earliest
things I remember you telling you saying
like in this island here if you board
Shield slide surf
whatever uh if you do the the whole
thing you like awarded something help
me oh wow where the hell are you oh you
you can't climb this can't get out of
this into the wall for ceiling uh okay
so I wish I I want to tip that stupid
thing over oh there that's a lift of air
bet your buddy
is oh man you can't I guess you oh I
thought I saw
arise uh so turn to your right and head
north NOP I lied head south to the
left oh you've got to go from the other
one I was so close once it's tough the
key the key is uh okay and you might and
you're definitely going to want to save
it the key is no we've broken so many
things I'll I'll try I'll try to make it
auto save or something you can uh oh
that's right we are just wrecking while
your gear I keep forgetting it's not my
sa
clearly if we uh yeah you get like an
auto save right yeah you know you can do
is just die right you could how about
you just die if you just died but it's
but it's only going to bring you back to
the last place at Auto yeah you're right
come on perfect Sun's
clearing
um oh I did dude I actually for the
first time did not see this
[Laughter]
[Music]
guy someone says to you should probably
eat something I agree all right all
right let's eat some food there is a
discomfort in
seeing a small amount of Hearts yeah
truffles baby
look like a king oh and it's rain again
die like an animal did you happen to get
it
oh did you get that out of Safe stupid
camera
ah oh take lift do it hit the lift
behind you I'm am I
coming coming right
up he is very
calm guess you can't really see his face
there's another one to the left there
make your
own are you
close oh it's not raining now it decides
to rain now it's raining that's
convenient it's cool you think no you
got any stamina up no or like elixir
where was that last auto
save
great if you go to the left I think
there's a
lift yeah take that
yeah you're good
yeah all
right I have a hard time killing
foxes because they're so damn cute
that's exactly right did I wait did I
cross an island oh I went one too far
what no no you're no you're good you're
good it's to your
right now you're left
yeah
yeah we really want that save oh Jesus
no do you know what it's going to do to
me no I don't it's going to make me
depressed for the rest of the day all
right
yeah like when I was doing it the key is
not to uh like just it barely touch it
yeah but I want it to look cool no I
know here you you get out of this
predicament this is not looking good is
it I'm calm what Peter are you up you're
upset cuz you lost all your stuff look
it let's look back I don't want to lose
all my stuff we could have done my save
no problem look at you're at the top of
the M wait a second oh never mind yeah
never mind you lost a lot of stuff today
I lost a guardian Shield that I really
love hey
man all don't be so materialistic you
said it you said it yourself got to
learn I'm superficial it wasn't about
the the object it's about how cool it
made me look yeah
Fair don't mind
me n I'm cool you can
stop you got me confused with someone
else I can't do anything about it I
think that's their meeting
ritual launching Rock
oh make love with me thanks oh I think
if you go to the other side to your
right I'm
good oh you can put on the Zora stuff
and swim faster that's a fantastic idea
thank you very much uhhuh I think it's
the
pants pantalones oo you have you have
the head right no I don't have the head
uh I don't have the uh pants it makes
you swim just if you hit Dash you'll
swim faster
yeah oh my God this guy
sucks I wasn't kidding I really like you
so here's a
problem
stop all right here we
go yeah how far will it take
you wow this is a cool fit this is going
pretty good oh okay all that crotch
shadow
where go to that side now no
no why did I
do wow I was
there what time we looking at what do we
got here
120 we got another half hour we want to
do what else another half
hour well well we could try that one
again or should we give up cuz it's
basically impossible let's go to a
different area should we should we end
it on this hey man it's your funeral oh
man that's a
challenge so this is the only place I
can go for
uh as far as that's to get to the height
yeah oh no so we can go here this is
good I think yeah so let's see we
probably uh go down here yeah maybe this
can work out o
oh man the thing about Wrecking in this
game too or I'm sorry on this area is
there's lava yeah don't drink don't
drink
lava you stuck that Landing what's this
his balls exploded
Jesus what was
that oh nothing dear
Robert um
this should be interesting oh you know
what else I got to change my FIT yeah I
was going to say let's see what happens
no we're good no no you're not we're
fine no no ni he's fine I have a hunch
that maybe you're not okay fine
something's telling
me don't you save my game I swear I
won't save your
game that's all I need right no it's
still that meter there is still still on
fire I think it will remain on fire no
matter what you wear you'll have to just
exit out to see what you you should be
fine with the two
pieces you're good you're good you're
good oh that's right so oh but you're
the bow that bow going to
melt oh it's the boomerang oh [__] don't
want to do that all right what can you
use now we don't need that we need this
this going to work all right so far if
you don't mind I'm going to change my
headgear here go for it what else you
work in with tiara Tiara oh these look
nice
classic okay all
right okay luch door hat yeah that's
good all right let's do it all right the
route
okay is this up or
down wait what is that metal rail to
your left have you not seen these no I
have but I've never seen them while
thinking about snowboarding no there's
no way but I guess the I guess the path
next to it is the route you want
right yeah I
suppose there's a Creeper down there
where oh he is staring at you nah this
is
butt is one eye is staring at you oh
nice Dodge oh this is working outow wow
okay yaa watch out for the lava excuse
me
come
on that was a very nervous one
oh good I'm having fun Zelda I'll be
there
later got some important work to do
important work to do important work to
do porn to do this is not working out
okay here we go do you know what those
do I would love to know maybe you put a
bomb
there have you done that
no it's got to mean
something maybe you can lift it with
magnesis maybe you got to hit it with an
arrow doesn't matter still on
fire nope all right well see you later
screw
it okay oh
mama oh
dude that felt really
interesting as in it like locked
no I should see your face right
now God damn
it uh how amazing would that
be God it's sliding the left shut up
link get
up you probably need a bigger Shield the
surface area on that one is a little bit
small
why aren't you sleep don't so don't
slide definitely is your fault parag
glad first drop on your
Shield or yeah come for that
way
almost all right maybe he's giving me a
sign this is all his fault it's the
whole melon banana
o all
right
kinda
kinda can I try I real quick yeah I'm
scared of I screwed up but maybe maybe
he'll be the best probably probably
not hey guy you got to get that guy he's
going to explode yeah fire meet
fire
[__]
D
no Focus how does one do this
again I don't know man yeah come on one
more
try this is the whole essence of the
Triforce
[Laughter]
let's hope at the
bottom H
[Laughter]
lizard no
problem I was like what for a second I
had no idea what you're doing I was like
why are you
just God the it's the Gap is so big one
more time yeah that's I know don't worry
it
happens how am I losing so much
health or how did that happen all these
wrecks
yeah long there's no way yeah now I
think about it I really felt like I had
a connection with this rail like a
spiritual connection yeah damn right
but
clearly it's a
liar God damn
it all right let's
bounce well that didn't work
o God I wonder if you can hate this part
you can bring that cart up and then jump
in it jump in under the cart from the
top of the
rail use magnesis you know what's funny
so
use I Justin just show me this oh just
Dro one in there and blow it up yeah
okay I didn't even realize you could do
that and not get
crushed okay so do now the question is
do you have enough
momentum
what is this what you're talking about
no I saying just jumping into it and
writing it down but yeah that's what I
was saying I have to turn it around why
do you have to turn it around because
I'll show
you so you can use the bomb yeah you you
could have used a bomb anyway if you
just left one
there if you just put one
behind whatever you do you
like do this nope
get
off it's going to be hella
sick you're going to lose that
cart too far
away dude you're losing
it get your ass back
here wouldn't
move
oh the bomb's
gone whatever this is not working
out let's just get out of
here this park sucks jump jump jump jump
jump wow that was so cool all of that
was so cool dude oh but we could but we
could use the link super jump at the end
of it how do you do that you do it I
don't even know if I have any left I'm
sorry that oh I got two left that
controller feels World cool that's it's
life it's why I'm on the stream with you
so feel you're after sweat just just
quiet
connection
uh do we have ADHD yes
yeah thank you guys for sticking with us
on uh this lovely stream I'm having a
lot of fun hope you guys are too Peter
are you having fun dude fun yes me I am
fun you friend fun you're hot this place
is hot
drink yeah this is going to be cool I
like where your head's
at
what go now do your bomb you're f
oh damn that was sick oh no we got 15
more
minutes what how do you engage
it you just I I know sorry Engage The
Jump you you hold down jump and then it
flashes green and then you
[Laughter]
go dude that was [__] really
funny so far that area right here has
been the best part of the stream and
we've done nothing where's my damn horse
kji he's never
[Laughter]
around H you know what if there's one
thing we learned
today Goron don't dive into lava well oh
you know how link will dive head first
if you jump into a body of water from
high enough yeah will he jump head first
into lava let's find out should I save
it
no um H that's a great idea I don't
think it's going to work we can try that
at the end we'll do it at the end oh man
can you imagine that IRL IRL oo it'd be
quick I
hope all right a
mine oh it's another one of these
things
gsh what gar g all right how about I
mean look at
that I could uh fire and brimstone buddy
all right the shield that Shield is
going to break uh I think it's red hot
like it's real good yeah
okay let's give it a shot here don't
yeah just ignore that that message it's
great what's that ostrich doing down
there
where what a
dummy dude head shot wow oh that's fried
chicken me are
hungry yeah I'm
link I'm linking I'm going to surf this
lava what I'm linking I'm going to surf
this it's easy on the drop it's going to
go just fine easy on the Pepsi Fuller
easy in Easy in it's going to work out
just
all right I'm just killing myself now uh
I feel like we didn't get to the right
area as far as steepness but also our
our Shields are going to break so quick
so it doesn't really matter
yeah well we I don't know we can come
back here and kill ourselves or we could
go or we could uh what's another area
you know there's this the starting
mountain sator yeah yeah let's do it
actually yes that one is is not too bad
yeah
is that the one that has like the
heart-shaped Little Pond up top where
you have to like introduce the gudo to
that guy that's like I'm super into her
I'm real nervous no I don't think so
this area I think
is is like the where the first uh runes
are like the real begin the first U
shrines excuse me where you
get yeah isn't it I didn't know that was
okay I guess I forgot that was on the
great Plateau I could be easily wrong
and you know judging by look of it I am
I am wrong the MOG Laton Shrine oh
that's yeah that's I get these so
confused I get MOG with log mixed up oh
uh huh what's that boy what's that boy
huh you smell lightning boy put on put
on the earrings oh you're wearing them
you're wearing them it's my earrings no
no no I'm saying the earrings will
protect you oh really yeah yeah yeah Oh
I thought I thought you were saying like
that's the only gear I I have that will
save you I'm wearing it I know I said
put them mine then I realized you were
already wearing them I tried to
backpedal
oh well what's no I want him to what's
doing it let it happen should I let it
happen oh so
good what was it was it the was it the
uh it I couldn't even
tell
mhm uh grooks kaban in the twitch chat
is asking if we're still going to go to
Ganon uh we've decided to Nix that part
of the plan uh one because it might take
longer than we expect to really get
through hyru castle like I've done it
but it definitely wasn't like a really
quick thing and then once we get to
genon that's going to be another like 15
20 minute fight uh also that's still
still kind of spoilery I think fairly
early to do that I think that's
definitely going to happen at some point
um yeah I mean we can certainly like
tell you guys that we're going to do it
and you cannot watch like spoiler
warnings are thing but right at the same
time um SC area that's right yeah and
the other thing is when Eric and I
streamed last week um yeah we we gave
oursel 15 minutes and it ended up
um being not enough time like you once
you get into that first like as far as
my only uh uh experience has been that
like outer first uh area of the castle
Yeah I mean there are enemies there but
you're you're very sneaky like you're
just you're not engaging if you wanted
to like get get any progress yeah well
the thing is just you got to roll deep
with ancient arrows man like once you've
got those equipped you can oneshot all
those enemies oh right I well I forgot
to mention that I had three hearts it
was like the first uh early games oh
right it was from the beginning yeah I
forgot men that so yeah it was uh pretty
difficult all right what's the boy going
to wear
today what are you going to wear
boy yes those those pants you love that
mask dude I love it that's the Chica
right um is it no it's the oh maybe no
it is right CH this happened
before no bow for
me what I didn't have any bows that no I
know I thought it was still going
on all right so what do you think well I
think you should
fart and get up on top of this that
power of yours oh that
that'll I love it what
this
nice okay I've definitely not been up
here and look at those
eggs I made an omelet the other day not
in real life in this
game it's pretty
good
how do you make it uh when you want to
throw something and you want to throw it
further I don't know if you can throw oh
watch
me Sports all right it wasn't a throw
whatever uh so this is a lot more steep
than I imagined oh and you are climbing
in the rain it's okay I'll get there
eventually oh
come on y
nice would you just stop being so cold
really eat me eat
eat oh I just wanted to keep eating
still kind of cold all
right oh what do you think wait look to
the right uh tilt the camera up is that
oh never mind I thought that was like a
straight line H to the right a little
bit I'm not I'm not seen a whole lot
here Peter but you're going for it yeah
that's
right yeah now this is
[Laughter]
good what was that again
nothing oh yeah
uh-huh I got a bad feeling about this
Shield
oh this one will last
longer yeah carve up that gravel yeah oh
this too
uh-oh you should hit a jump soon oh
these rocks are going to do it no you're
going to
get oh did it get hit by
lightning I think it got struck by
lightning did it it kind of just has
that same look that same
Flash oh we are losing these Quick
aren't
we
[Laughter]
yes oh man come to me
hores oh wait a minute why didn't I
think of this before
what oh you can't freeze a horse no come
here I got no more Shields we got seven
minutes left all right we should end it
in a
very amazing way let's go back to hebra
if you got if you guys yeah let's end it
on on a good run actually cuz we've had
some you know we tried well yeah we
tried and we failed we put we put areas
to the test
and I think the agreement is that hebra
is the place to board yeah basically and
you got your choice of
runs
uh what more do you
need your Shield won't break every 20
seconds I mean you could get some good
hunting done oh remember
this I never forget
well were you going to say I'm sorry I
don't remember I'm now distracted by it
I need this again look look at me
boy look at me when I'm talking to
[Laughter]
you like this like this
oh take the shot Steve come on take the
shot take it it's it's blurry hold on
link one more just one more wait I'm
shooting a video by accident wait oh I'm
out of store
all
right shut up okay what what run what do
you think no I mean you're the Hebrew
man okay well I think uh this
way yeah yeah we say B yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh look at
this oh oh give me a give me a can you
do goofy almost
almost I feel like you can't do that I
feel like you can't no I didn't look
like you could it sucks it does suck
this game sucks four out of
10 yeah yeah link
yeah perfect perfect no I needed
that all
right oh yeah yeah yeah right pass the
main [__] should I hit this all the way
up yeah okay okay okay all right
okay okay whoa that looked
weird oh man can you imagine that ice on
your bare feet I I can't jump where you
going what are you doing I'm trying to
jump up here we go don't worry we're
good oh you know what actually I changed
my mind I know the good way it's this
way prove it spin it
yeah it's actually this
way oo what's Su dog hey
doggo good boy
boy
yeah uh-oh I forgot we're not in a very
friendly
environment good boy
yeah in the butt
[Laughter]
oh I could not have asked for a better
reaction he's like
huh oh
yeah oh W oh you almost got two for
one this was the pass I like oh they're
pissed sorry this is the right one look
at this secret little area here
oh dang
it nan nan
nan
everything a man if only you could
tether to the Moose and had to pull you
oh three out of 10 yep man this game
just keeps getting
worse yeah feel like every stream we do
from now on this game's not going to end
up anywhere near a perfect
score
yeah yeah there it is uh-huh feeling it
up
up yeah
yeah oh uhoh uhoh
uhoh
is there a
doctor I would love a real life snow
park like this in my Park we have giant
snowballs roll down the mountain that'll
free up the
slopes get your ass
down
yeah oh come on dude dude hurry up the
bunny Hills that way God damn dude hi
what's up
this is like GTA cinematic
mode ah
weak see this is a good run look at this
this is pretty good pretty good like
it's long it's making me rethink maybe
this is a five out of
10 oh is my shield damaged I got a
solution for
you
yeah
you know I said I didn't like killing
foxes I love killing foxes I love it now
yeah yeah more mama wolf oh I know what
we're going to
do more speed yes good mhm
yeah Yep this is what I want
drop
come
on a rats Shrek Shrek
file all
right this is how we're going to end
it oh
man
TR okay okay all
right this is
it you just going to plow into that
door read my
mind be the force knock
knock oh was just so cooler all right
well let's uh wrap that up find a good
way to go out yeah that was a little
antil climatic
but yeah uh-huh wait
[Laughter]
uh-huh that's it
okay uh all right well thank you guys so
much for watching yeah this was uh the
first of many episodes of uh
Triforce me and Rob we're GNA just do
dumb [__] we're gonna try to figure out
what we can do in Zelda um if you have
any ideas stuff You' like to see us mess
around with just let us know uh on
Twitter just Rob Handler Robert robt and
I'm PC Brown you can hit us up there
please do uh or tweet a Gamespot with
any ideas or uh yeah so again thanks for
watching have a great Thursday see you
guys and sign
off